foreign
so the team has teed up this video I
want to get your reaction okay you ready
let's do this
for Lego enthusiasts Lucas electric
these aren't just toys this is the Lego
Creator Palace Cinema
there's serious money makers that he
buys and sells for profit the biggest
online database of collectible Lego sets
lists 1.2 billion dollars worth of the
toys around the world you know Lego Tron
up here we're in the three to four
hundred dollar range this Lego Tie
Fighter 200 a piece is what these are
selling the returns that I typically
will see is somewhere between 150 to 250
percent on a Lego set researchers say
electric is one of tens of thousands who
concerned by the recent volatility of
stocks and bonds are betting on the
reliable returns from this tiny but
growing Market
wow dude move over crypto yeah Back That
Thing Up Beanie Babies wow we have a new
toy in town okay so this brings me to an
article John here's the headline for you
adults are buying toys for themselves
and it's the biggest source of growth
for the industry and there's a new name
for these people they are called kidults
they have a great fondness for cartoons
superheroes Star Wars Lego and in recent
years toy makers like Mattel have
created Lines Just for these consumers
because they're stupid that's why well
think about it they have the Nostalgia
and they have the buying power they've
got money now right you know how many
times I've tried to convince my wife
that this new guitar or hunting it's
like deer rifle is an investment yeah no
my truck is an investment it's uh it's
gonna depreciate and then suddenly
re-appreciate it yeah you know who can't
afford this kids and so uh I mean it's
astronomically expensive these days but
there's some fascinating stuff in here
uh in the article and there's one that's
connected to it that's interesting
investing in Lego more lucrative than
gold a study suggestions okay I hate
these ah gosh you're giving me
hemorrhoids I hate these
the worst the worst the worst the worst
so I'm a hundred percent for buying toys
if you got it buy whatever dude if you
got the money have a great time you've
got your weird Hobbies I've got so many
weird hobbies and my son is down with
the Legos I love them I dude I can sit
there and do Legos all day it's quiet we
put on some music it's awesome I love
Legos I love them I love them
to lie to yourself and others about them
being a investment property
dude
if it all goes down
we'll be trading in Legos right and
someone comes to my house and they're
like hey I've got a tin of coffee and
some cigarettes can I have a Starfighter
Lego set it's not gonna happen it's not
gonna happen it's it's trading more
lucrative than gold because we have more
money than since
and there's more circulating dollars
which means there's more of things we
can buy and there's people right now on
Etsy or eBay or whatever going that
guy's full of crap what an idiot
whatever you're cool
keep buying and selling
toys knock your lights out rock onto the
breaking on dude
you're gonna be sitting I I dude I'm
just sitting with people who've got a
lot of guitars they got a lot of guns
they've got a lot of whatever
this is my investment bro we'll sell
some
they're getting way less than they
thought on on average or it's it's all
it's just imaginary dude it's just like
we all have those Beanie Babies In The
Attic where we were going oh I could
have sold those at one point I don't
have a beanie baby I know you have a
huge collection I sold mine okay I don't
know I don't know where they went John
but yes we all have things they're like
no it's worth uh this much bro but it's
pretty I mean it's a fascinating stat if
you just look at it oh it is it is it is
the market for secondhand Lego rises in
value by 11 annually which is faster and
better than the rate of return than gold
stocks bonds stamps and wine in the last
decade or two when there's been the
single highest wealth accumulation in
the history of planet earth mostly
over this we can get that's a whole
other conversation so yes
congratulations yeah I think it's
collecting guys I'd rather you uh invest
in Lego than stamps so I you know
there's some good things there but I
will say the company Lego they are
genius marketers and here's how they did
this John uh they use limited production
runs they use collector special editions
huge and scarcity on the second hand
Market that is what has kept these
prices up it's simply supply and demand
and they are so good at creating the
scarcity the urgency you'll never get
this collector set again everything's a
collector set now it's like blood Legos
right that's how it goes it's
unbelievable so uh great lesson in
marketing terrible investment I'd rather
you be investing in your retirement and
if you want to just enjoy Legos and it's
a collector thing for you yeah there's a
bunch of them you've already maxed out
retirement you don't have any debt
you're using your fun money that's great
we are happy for you we're not mad at
those adults out there
but please do not delay your retirement
because you're like oh but honey if I
get this Lego set it's going to be worth
way more than my retirement account or
here's here's like let's here's me being
like
honest
man if you if you buy Legos and collect
Legos and they go up in value and you're
buying great and I can't I didn't I
can't argue with the data the last
decade man these things have done great
awesome they're going up in value so
you're you're an adult you're a
collector you're going to buy some
expensive Lego sets that are rare
awesome
what I don't like about these kind of
studies that get dropped out with
headlines like this is that
people who watch too much YouTube
then go I'm missing the boat here and
they start buying Lego sets with credit
cards they start buying quote-unquote
great deals with fill in the blank ways
of borrowing money
with the idea that I'm this is gonna
return me 11 I could sell this for 400 I
only bought it for 50 and I bought on a
credit card and that's the that's the
folks who get in trouble if you buy
these things with cash and you end up
with a huge pile of Legos in the
apocalypse yes no harm no foul it's fine
right
but dude if you have a pilot debt buying
these things with the hope you're going
to pay off you're just going to get in a
long line of crypto folks and long-line
Beanie Baby folks in the long line of
tulip folks and and on and on and on
right
yeah we we don't know the future of Lego
I mean one thing could take they could
do have a tweet that takes them down and
the stock I'll keep rocking with Legos
I'm all about it but but it's a it's
very very risky and we see this across
all other Industries John sneakers or
there's a lot of sneaker heads out there
and they're buying the collector's shoe
and there's a lot of urgency and
scarcity and so whenever there's a lot
of urgency and scarcity I like to just
pause and go why am I actually why do I
have this fomo yeah and I go oh it's
marketing got it oh I don't actually
need it it's not actually a great
investment I actually don't know
anything about it and so unless you're a
super Lego fan who just knows the ins
and outs and knows exactly what set is
what value on eBay don't get involved in
the stuff for the investment Do It For
the Love of Lego yeah because you want
it for the Love For the Love of Lego you
have a t-shirt that says that man